these are questions from the independent
in the uk and the first question is how
does he i'm assuming that's me sal how
does he see the development in video
conferencing particularly new services
like google hangouts as affecting the
provision of distance learning is that
something that he sees the khan academy
using and in what kind of time frame so
interesting question so there's a couple
of layers here first of all
just kind of the idea of distance
learning and this is where you know i
think right now everything that's online
learning kind of gets grouped into you
know distance learning and online
learning and all of the same and most
people kind of don't don't really
differentiate between what they are
right now what what's happening with
distance learning is that they are for
the most part very similar what happens
in physics physical classes it's just
the people aren't in the same room so
distance learning fundamentally they
still involve um when some you know when
someone is participating in the learning
there's a a live professor or teacher on
the other side of that and they still
are kind of signing up for courses they
still meet at a certain time
to do their courses or to do their
interactions and so i would call it much
more in the in the domain of synchronous
learning which means that all the
parties have to be there at the same
time and that all the students are also
kind of moving along at the same pace so
it really is exactly as the physical
model it's just they've taken the the
idea that you have to be in the same
place
what what khan academy khan academy
isn't the only version of this but khan
academy we kind of view it as more of an
asynchronous model
so asynchronous which really just means
that things aren't necessarily happening
at the same place which is the idea that
i could record this video right now and
you don't have to be listening to it
right now you might listen to this video
an hour later or a day later or a year
later and so you can really go through
things at your own pace and so
we don't view video conferencing as
maybe our main delivery mechanism
although distance learning um you know
vendors or companies or schools might
view video conferencing as their main
way to get to people we think hey we can
record videos they can
people can consume those at their own
pace and we can give people exercises
and feedback that they can they can do
at their own base where we do
think video conferencing could be really
really really interesting this is
something that we have not that we have
not done yet we've kind of thrown around
the idea and we just really have to get
the bandwidth to address it
is
i think video conferencing is a
is an amazing way to have peer-to-peer
interactions
so peer-to-peer i'll just do the acronym
peer-to-peer interactions so right now
in a lot of the classrooms that are
piloting khan academy or even the ones
that are doing it on their own
and this is what we really advocate is
every student works at their own pace
but when they're stuck either the
teacher intervenes based on the data
that the teacher sees or even better a
student intervenes and helps their peer
and we think that that can that there's
no reason why that has to be sit just in
a physical classroom that you could
actually transcend a physical classroom
and that's where something like video
conferencing could be really valuable if
two people could share a blackboard that
looks very similar like this and they
have either a tablet device or a pen
tablet like what i'm using right now
they can run a tutoring session with
each other it would even be cool if they
could record it and it could be archived
for for other people uh to use it in the
future so so that is is really powerful
and that's mainly in the tutoring space
so that you can have peer-to-peer
tutoring
tutoring or really teaching or mentoring
even and the other interesting place
where peer-to-peer interactions could be
interesting i think this is completely
untapped is the whole idea of assessment
right now khan academy the assessment
piece happens you're doing exercises it
keeps track of how you're doing
in a traditional classroom assessments
are some form of paper exam it could be
multiple choice could be free answer it
could be essay exam but what i think
most of us have always appre realized is
that the most the highest form of
assessment is either the practical
assessment or the oral assessment so
practical would literally mean you know
if you're if you're starting to be a
nurse someone observe you while you're
trying to you know insert an iv into
someone's into someone's
arm and oral examination and this is
really the gold standard for what we see
in the academia is look when you're when
you're going through your qualifiers
there's an oral part of that examination
and then essentially you'll sit in front
of a room full of faculty members and
they'll grill you on and make sure you
really really really do understand a
concept deeply and so what we think we
could do where on the peer-to-peer side
is eventually have not only just the
kind of assessment that we already have
in place at khan academy but maybe an
oral assessment where you know right now
maybe you are a we don't have the proper
words for it but maybe you are a level
one
you're level one in trigonometry or
level one in algebra and you wanna go
you to become level 2 in trigonometry
you want to get into this this like a
smaller circle this more elite circle of
people who've gotten to this deep level
of trigonometry and to do that maybe on
a baseline you have to do some you have
to show that you've done something on
kind of the traditional exercises on
khan academy at your own pace and and
you've been able to prove competency
there but to really make it then you
would have an oral examination with
maybe five people from level two
five people from level two and if maybe
four out of the five say that you are
ready for level two then you will be
bumped up to level two and then one of
your responsibilities is someone in
level two is it to
assess future people for level from
level one coming from level one and then
of course then your next aspiration is
to go to level three or go become a
master of all of the math or whatever
you might want to say so i think
peer-to-peer interactions could be
really really powerful when it comes to
the assessment part i think you know i'd
be hard-pressed to see how this isn't
more rigorous than really all the
assessment that has in place because
you're all you're not just being
assessed by arbitrary peers you're being
assessed by peers who've already really
proven themselves to to really deeply
understand the concept
the other things um
you know when you say is is this
is this that's something that he sees
the khan academy using and what kind of
timeframe well once again we do see
ourselves using it but we don't know the
time frame it's just a bandwidth issue
and oh that reminds me so the other area
where i think video conferencing could
be really powerful is in the idea of
foreign language so once again the gold
standard in foreign language is really
immersion but uh that's obviously not
always possible or economically possible
but the second best thing to immersion
is actually having live interactions
with people on the other side of the
world or maybe even not on the other
side of the world
you know one thing i want to do with my
two and a half year old is maybe get him
a skype or maybe a google plus buddy or
whatever it is
in different countries so that he can
start chatting with kids maybe his own
age or a little older a little younger
and they can just start to at least get
the basics of each other's languages and
start to teach each other so i think it
has it could have a lot to be done in
not full immersion but pseudo immersion
in for for foreign language for foreign
language learning and then a lot of the
core for the foreign language like the
vocabulary and the grammar
we could probably do our exercise
platform but this is really what gives
you that deeper understanding of it
the next question is is there a
possibility of khan academy's
qualifications achievements being
externally validated at some point such
that they're recognized internationally
as a measure of academic achievement so
there definitely is a possibility and we
are exploring to see to see how
what
how can we validate that when someone
does something on khan academy that is
really coming from them and we think
there are ways to do it we could even
have you know places where you could go
and you could show your id or whatever
and say hey look this is me um i'm not
going to do the khan academy there and
then we could validate yes this was
definitely the person who who did that
and then once you do that we could we
could we we could give badges or
validations that look this person really
does know that information and then it's
it's a matter of making sure that they
are accepted um broadly and i think this
actually touches on a generalized
problem
in that right now you have and i've
talked about this in in other videos and
other
lectures right now education is kind of
a mixture of you have the learning part
you have the learning part you have the
credentialing part
credentialing part and then you have a
little bit of a socialization part
socialization you have a little bit of
socialization and when you go to a
university and you pay the big tuition
you're kind of you know you're getting
all of this stuff and depending who you
ask different people think they're
paying for providing different things if
you ask most students at most
universities they're probably most
focused on the credential but if you ask
most of the universities they'll say hey
no all of our resources are going to
this right over here the credential is
just to make sure that you know people
are going the
are are learning the things but they're
actually spending the resources over
here and so that question i think about
whether khan academy can give
credentials or frankly whether third
party can get credentials i think is
just the whole issue of can we decouple
this can we separate can we se can we
create a line of separation between the
learning side of education and the
credentialing side and i think if you do
that generally something really powerful
happens if we can create and it doesn't
have to come from khan academy it can
come from a government it could come
from ngos it could come from who knows
where it comes from if there is an
internationally recognized battery of
examinations
assessments and deep assessments they
can be practical they could be oral they
could be paper based all of the above
and so if you have something like this
that is internationally recognized
then all of a sudden the rest of the
education world will compete right over
here and then their students will just
try to get this thing right over here
and what's exciting about something like
that is then khan academy could compete
on equal footing because if students who
choose to go through khan academy for
free perform just as well on that as the
student who's you know spending tens of
thousands of dollars then or maybe
certain students who say well this just
works better for me or maybe some
students will just learn on the job
they'll learn on the job or they'll
learn from textbooks but it allows
students to learn the best way they can
the best way that fits their career and
even their economic situation and the
other good thing is if this is
internationally recognized it solves the
problem that
right now there are some big name
schools that if you are if you're if
you're lucky enough to attend one of
those schools you do have something on
your resume that anywhere in the world
or anywhere in the country someone might
recognize it but the problem is most
universities aren't internationally
recognized or aren't recognized broadly
beyond one region and so you have
students who are doing this really
really well right now they're learning
or they're potentially learning really
well at their maybe at their regional
university or their community college
and then they get this credential and
then they get this credential right over
here but this credential is not
universally recognized it's not they go
to the neighboring state or the
neighboring country and people don't
know how to assess that credential this
way those students who really do learn
their material well will be able to take
these external asses assessments and
prove that they know it just as well as
the student who went to oxford or
harvard